I you know it's funny it's like it kind
of comes back to like what do we think
is gonna be natural or not I mean if you
put if you you know took someone from 50
years ago or a hundred years ago or 250
years ago and you know showed them
modern society they would think it was
the most unnatural screwed up thing
they'd ever seen and the way that we
interacted with each other would seem so
completely wrong and unnatural to them
that that it's just because like you
know they were there their relations and
their relationships in their world was
based on a completely different way of
viewing things so I don't necessarily
worry too much i mean identity is
something that i think is very very you
know it's always been fluid it's just
that now we it's just a matter of like
how you know technology's just made it
so maybe more fluid than it would have
before i think especially for young
people they don't necessarily don't
worry about this stuff and they don't
worry about you know privacy because
it's it's not necessarily there aren't
necessary a lot of you know it's not
actually a big issue for them and I
think they are figuring out what parts
of themselves they want to really reveal
online and you know just because you
know someone can take you know fine look
at private photos of you on facebook or
whatever I mean if you're worried about
that don't post them in the first place
I don't really post photos of myself on
facebook and I don't have a personal
blog and a Twitter feed but I don't
necessarily reveal very much about my
private life on those things and if
those things if you're not putting those
things out there yourself on the odds
are that they're not going to be
revealed and I think you know people are
sort of negotiating and figuring out
what's the right balance how much do
they want to put out there and there are
some people who are going to want to put
out more and those people will will
become sort of you know I've become web
celebrities and and and you know have
their their fan bases and things like
that and they're people who are not
going to want to you know put as much of
them out there and they might you know
when I besides different parts of their
lives or or whatever I mean it's it's
it's something that I think you know
people are figuring out and it doesn't
seem to me as big of a deal